okay in this lesson we're going to talk
about inequalities and special cases of
inequalities so let's get right into
this video and like i say in a lot of
the other lessons you want to make sure
you uh take some time to pause the video
see if you can solve these problems on
your own and then go ahead and check it
with me and make sure you're
understanding the concept so
example number one it says which is
equivalent to 5y minus 3x is less than
2y plus 12. and if we scan down the
answers that's what i usually recommend
when you're doing the act is read the
question kind of quickly first glance at
the answer so you know what form that
it's in so that'll kind of help to
structure the way that you approach the
problem and you can see that all these
you know x is by itself so what we want
to do is we want to solve for x okay and
so let's go ahead and do that by
subtracting 5y from both sides of the
inequality so that gives us negative 3x
is less than so we subtract 5y so that's
going to make this negative 3y plus 12.
now i want to get just x by itself so
i'm going to do the opposite of
multiplying by negative 3 i'm going to
divide everything by negative 3. these
cancel and you can see that this is
going to be x is greater than
y minus 4. now notice what happened
there whenever you multiply or divide
both sides of the inequality by a
negative number or if you multiply you
know multiply or divide either one the
inequality sign is going to change
direction okay it doesn't matter if you
add or subtract a negative number it
doesn't matter if there's positive or
negative numbers in your inequality what
matters is if you yourself are
multiplying or dividing by a negative
number then the sign changes direction
so it looks like here the best answer is
going to be letter c
okay now for example 2
it just says solve for x so we're just
trying to get x by itself so what i'm
going to do here is i'm going to
subtract 3x from both sides of the
inequality okay so if i do that these
are going to cancel we get 21 is greater
than
3x plus 3. i'm going to subtract 3 from
both sides
so that gives us let's see 18 is greater
than 3x and i'm going to divide both
sides by 3 and you can see that x is
less than 6. now when you solve your
inequality
what you want is you want that variable
to be on the left side of the inequality
sign so if you have to if you get the
variable here on the right just
visualize picking this entire thing up
and flipping it over so if i do that
here's x here's 6. now see how it's
pointing to the x you still want the
inequality sign pointing to the x and
opening to the six so x is less than six
that's how you would want to write that
final
inequality okay now the last example
this is a good one
it says which of the following is the
set of all real numbers such that you
know this inequality is true right
empty set all positive numbers all
negative numbers are all real numbers
well let's go ahead and solve it let's
see
so first thing i'm going to do is i'm
going to distribute the 2 so that gives
us 2x minus 6 is greater than or equal
to i'm going to combine like terms here
negative 10 plus 4 is uh
negative 6 so that's 2x minus 6. now
when you look at this
you notice that this is an identity
meaning that the left side and the right
side are identical
so
no matter what you put in for x
the left side and the right side are
going to be exactly the same so you see
this little bar here that means equal to
right greater than or equal to so what
that means is that this is going to be
true for all real numbers no matter what
you put in for x that's going to be true
now if i was to change the problem
slightly by getting rid of the
equal sign
is 2x minus 6
greater than 2x minus 6 no it's equal to
so then it would be the empty set so it
means that you know there would not be a
value of x that would make this side
just greater than this side so what you
want to do is you want to make sure that
if you get the same quantity that you
analyze it right now another situation
that comes up like say for example you
solved it
and let's say it was like 2x minus 8 is
greater than
2x plus 4 okay
if you subtract 2x from both sides
notice that you're left with negative 8
is greater than 4 so that variable that
cancels out on both sides of the
inequality and you're just left with
these constants okay these numbers
that's when you want to ask yourself hmm
is negative eight greater than four no
this is this is never going to be true
right so that means this would be no
solution or the empty set if it was the
other way around okay say i switched it
like this negative 8 is always less than
4 then it would be all real numbers so
that's kind of a special case of the
inequalities so a couple things to
remember
these special cases here as well as if
you multiply or divide by a negative
number that inequality sign flips
important things for you to remember
when you take the a c t